thank you all for coming we have an
awesome task here we have six highly
distinguished panelists and something
less than 90 minutes to solve the
world's problems six months ago it was
six months ago now that the Lehman
debacle occurred that AIG has rescued
that Bank of America bought Merrill
Lynch about six months ago that the tarp
funds started being distributed only on
Monday are we going to find out what's
really on the bank balance sheets this
frightens me we've been operating it
seems to me with so little information
the the so-called stress tests will be
outed I think it says something about
the way government has managed this
economy the economy was doing fairly
poorly in much of 2008 and then fell off
the cliff in the last quarter of 2008
and into 2009 growing falling at a 6%
annual rate an extraordinary drop in our
national income it is now by some very
important measures the worst economic
recession and post-world War two the
post-world War two ERA employment has
dropped faster than ever before in this
space of time industrial production and
by many other criteria it's almost the
worst and it isn't over yet the one last
thing I want to say what gives us all
the jitters is that this is a three font
front problem a housing market that went
crazy and the bubble burst a credit
crisis the most severe we've known since
the early 1930s and now a sharp drop in
demand for goods and services and
capital investment leading to a severe
recession what gives us the jitters is
that all of these are related and can
make all those other factors worse I'm
not going to talk anymore because we
want to hear what our panelists have to
say my job is to try to keep us to time
I've asked each of them to comment in
the first 6 or 7 minutes in their
introductory remarks
on what the current state of the economy
is many people are saying they're green
shoots we have seen some deceleration in
the decline of the economy green shoots
are showing what is the actual state of
the economy and do we need a serious
mid-course correction on the part of the
government do we have to change policy
and what we should do all of that in six
or seven minutes for each of us
let's go immediately to Senator Bradley
and again I will try and keep us on time
senator oh thanks very much Jeff it's an
honor for me to be on this panel I look
around the distinguished historians and
economists and financiers and wonder
what I'm doing here
but I assume that I'm here because I
think that any solution to the problem
certainly even defining the problem that
we're facing has to be able to be
defined so the average guy understands
and the solution to the problem has to
be given so that the slightly above
average guy understands so how are we
along the recovery I mean when city core
drops from sixty to one and then comes
back to three I don't think that's a
recovery when Warren Buffett buys GE and
goldman sachs and after he buys that it
drops 45 to 50 percent and that if he's
going to even break even he's got her 9%
for the next 12 years I don't think
that's a recovery if you look at what we
should do about this on the one hand the
administration has put in place measures
that if they were to work could offer
some hope what I'd like to suggest is if
they don't work there's an alternative
and I'd like to put it this way you know
we have essentially spent about twelve
point seven trillion dollars in
commitments and actually spent a little
over four trillion dollars in this
crisis some institutions such as city
core for example received about sixty
billion in direct assistance and 340
billion
in guarantees so the US taxpayers into
Citicorp for about 400 billion dollars
so I look at this and I say if we look
out to June July and the PPI program is
not succeeding the assets aren't being
bought at levels that they should be
bought from the bank's a book from the
books of banks that there is an
alternative because in the interim
between now and then there will have
been a stress test few banks will be
identified who knows it might even be
postponed and also secretary Geithner
will have the authority to come in and
deal effectively and forcefully with
non-bank financial institutions so when
I look at - July August PPI P isn't
working the stress tests have been
delayed there was an argument about to
have whether the government is right or
the banks are right but clearly there
are a few that are in very serious
problems and you have the secretary with
that new authority you think back to
city core we put 400 billion dollars
into it I looked at the ticker today the
market cap of Citicorp 17 billion
dollars so the government could buy
Citicorp for a fraction of what we've
already obligated the taxpayer for and
in buying city core as an example could
be a other one or two others
it wouldn't government announced in four
to six months we're going to sell these
assets the good assets back to the
public who wouldn't pay for the largest
depositor base in the world and if you
bought city core for let's say 20
billion dollars what would it be worth
if you sold the good Bank back to the
public and I mean the public I don't
mean selling it to hedge funds although
they can participate but I would do it
as a rights offering to any American who
wants to invest in this good Bank I
think the very prospect of that
happening would be bring very strong
positive
of influence on the development of the
whole economy and what would the
government then be left with the
government would then be left with the
bad Bank it would be left with the
assets that were going through loops now
to try to get off of the bank books and
instead the government would have them
we could take 20 to 15 to 20 years to to
clean them up so when I look at this I
say I'd like to see the existing program
work if it doesn't work there is an
alternative and it's an alternative in
the long run the average guy in America
could participate in Thank You senator
just six minutes very impressive
professor Fergusson well Jeff panelists
ladies and gentlemen we are living
through historic times this is the end
of the age of leverage which began I
guess in the late 1970s and saw an
explosive rise are in the ratio of debt
to gross domestic product not only in
this country but in many many other
countries once you end up with debts
public public and private debts in
excess of three and a half times the
size of your annual output you are
Argentina
you know it's it's funny that the people
refer all the time back to the Lehman
crisis let's remember that this crisis
actually began in June 2007 it fully
became clear in August of 2007 that
major financial institutions were almost
certainly on the brink of insolvency to
anybody who bothered to think about the
impacts of subprime defaults on their
balance sheets but we were in denial for
an extraordinarily long time people both
highly sophisticated and laypeople
refused to believe what was happening
which is why I called it the great
repression and we stayed in denial until
September more than a year later of last
year and then we had the breakdown
you'll notice how psychological terms
are very helpful when economics fails as
a discipline as it clearly has so we
retreat into the realm of psychology
after the repression the breakdown we
came out of denial and we realized that
probably more than one major bank was
insolvent and in September and October
the world went into shock it was deeply
traumatic now we're in the therapy phase
and what therapy are we using well it's
very interesting because we're using two
quite contradictory courses of therapy
one is the prescription of dr. Friedman
Milton Friedman that is and that's the
therapy that's being administered by the
Federal Reserve massive ejections of
liquidity to avert the kind of banking
crisis that caused the Great Depression
of the early 1930s and fine with that
that's the right thing to do
but there's another course of therapy
that is simultaneously being
administered which is the therapy
prescribed by dr. Keynes John Maynard
Keynes and that therapy involves the
running of massive fiscal deficits in
excess of twelve percent of gross
domestic product this year and the
issuance therefore
a vast quantities of freshly minted
bonds now you know there's some medicine
in your drugs cabinet at home that has
passed its sell-by date and I rather
fear at the risk of provoking the man
sitting on the other side of me that it
says 1936 on the bottle of doctor
Keynes's medicine why do I think this
because there's a clear contradiction
between these two policies and we're
trying to have it both ways you can't be
a monetarist and a Keynesian
simultaneously at least I can't see how
you can because if the aim of the
monetarist policy is to keep interest
rates down to keep liquidity high the
effect of the Keynesian policy must be
to drive interest rates up after all
1.75 trillion dollars is an awful lot of
freshly minted Treasuries to land on the
bond market at a time of recession and I
still don't quite know who's going to
buy all this stuff it's certainly not
going to be the Chinese that works fine
in the good times but what I call chai
America the marriage between China and
America is sort of coming to an end
maybe it's going to end in a messy
divorce no the problem is that only the
Fed can buy these freshly minted
Treasuries and there is going to be I
predict in the weeks and months ahead a
very painful tug of war between our
monetary policy and our fiscal policy as
the markets realize just what a vast
quantity of bonds are going to have to
be absorbed by the financial system this
year that will tend to drive the price
of the bonds down that will tend to
drive up the interest rates and that
will have an effect also on mortgage
rates the precise opposite of what Ben
Bernanke is trying to achieve at the Fed
one final thought I don't want to make a
speech I'd rather engage in in a
conversation one final thought let's not
think of this as a purely American
phenomenon let's not be parochial if we
possibly can be this is a crisis of the
global economy I'd go so far as to say
it's a crisis of globe
itself the US economy is not going to
contract the most this year even if the
worst projections of the IMF turn out to
be right 2.6 percent contraction is far
far less than the shop already being
inflicted on Japan are on South Korea on
Taiwan to say nothing of the shock being
inflicted on Europe the German economy
is contracting at somewhere close to
five or six percent so we are faced not
just with a problem to be dealt with by
American policy we are faced with a
crisis of global proportions and it's
far from clear to me that the
prescriptions of dr. Friedman and dr.
Keynes together can solve that massive
global crisis thank you neon so I think
there will be some disagreement on this
panel professor Krugman well yeah I
think I should respond to that a bit let
let me let me say actually I wish that
we actually still if people have
remembered that 1936 medication a little
bit better one of the problems we face
in all of this is what I have referred
to as the great forgetting we learned a
great deal about how economies can be in
crisis during the 1930s we took a number
of prophylactic measures to prevent
anything like that from happening ever
again
and a very large part of how we got into
this crisis is that we forgot all of
that we forgot what our grandfathers
knew that we we forgot that banking
systems need to be very carefully
regulated and watched over because
banking crises can do terrible damage we
forgot that the financial markets are
not in fact calm rational places that
they they really need to be
circumscribed and so we got into this
and one of the really disappointing
things I found as the crisis came upon
us is it also turns out that we've
forgotten a lot of the sort of basic
macroeconomics of this kind of problem
what what I actually called a no
depression economics and in in the book
that in a much revised version I was
reissued last year
and I think it's actually it goes
directly from Neal's point here because
let's think about put put think about
what is actually happening to the global
economy right now what's happening is on
the one side there has been an abrupt
realisation by many people that they
have too much debt that they are over
indebted that they are not as rich as
they thought US households have seen
their net worth decline abruptly by
thirteen trillion dollars and there are
similar blows occurring around the world
so the people individual households want
to save again so the United States has
gone from approximately a zero savings
rate two years ago up to about four
percent right now which is still below
historical norms but suddenly saving is
occurring that's saving ought to be
translated into investment but the
investment demand is not there housing
flat on its back because it was over
built housing bubbles not only in the
United States but across much of Europe
collapsed many businesses cannot get
access to capital because of the
breakdown of the financial system but
even those that do have access to
capital don't want to invest because
because demand consumer demand is not
there between the housing bust and the
sudden decision of consumers that maybe
they actually ought to save after all
we're we have a world that with lots of
excess capacity and so if you the this
GDP report that just came out says that
business fixed investment
non-residential fixed investment
essentially business investment is
falling at a forty percent annual rate
so investment is falling through ground
and this causes a problem lots of people
want to save fast increase in the
desired savings not only the United
States but around the world combined
with a sharp decline in the amount that
the private sector is willing to invest
even at a zero interest rate or rather
even at a zero interest rate of for US
government debt which is what the
Federal Reserve has the most direct
impact on and one way to think about
what we have right now is a global
crisis
caused by a vast excess of desired
savings over willing investment we have
a global savings glut there's just not
enough you know another way to say is we
have a global shortage of demand those
are equivalent ways of saying the same
thing so we have this global savings
glut which is why there is in fact no
effort upward pressure on interest rates
there is more savings than we know what
to do with if we ask the question where
will the savings come from to finance
these large US government deficits the
answer is from ourselves at the margin
the Chinese are not contributing at all
those extra savings are in effect the
savings that Americans wanted to do
anyway but that US business is not
willing to invest under current
conditions that is actually why
Keynesian policy works in the short run
it takes excess desired savings and
translates into them into some kind of
spending if the private sector won't do
it the government will there is actually
no contradiction between the Federal
Reserve's actions and the actions of the
US government with a fiscal stimulus
it's very much necessary to do both the
Federal Reserve is essentially going out
there and playing the role that the
private banking system is no longer
playing properly by buying a lot of
private securities the federal
government is going out there and
borrowing and playing the role that
businesses are not play are not willing
to play by by engaging an investment all
that debt financed infrastructure
spending is it's basically filling the
hole left by the collapse in business
investment in the United States it's not
a there is not an excess demand for
savings that is going to drive up
interest rates the only thing that might
drive up interest rates and this is a
real concern is that people may grow
dubious about the financial solvency of
governments so there are real problems
the United States is not there yet I
think we have probably a substantial
ways to run but other countries less so
Ireland is being forced to raise taxes
and cut spending because of fears about
its solvency despite a deep recession
the UK is fairly close to the edge
because people are worried about the
cost of financial bailout but but for
the United States that is certainly not
an issue now the the great concern I
have is that although we understand
these
fairly well early some of us do the
found actually is referring to Neil I'm
actually referring to I'm actually
referring to the to the 38 Republican
senators who said that the answer for
this is another round of Bush style tax
cuts they cost three trillion dollars of
the next decade but the the the great
problem we face is that the scale of the
crisis has overwhelmed the response that
this is not a qualitatively this is not
a crisis that we didn't know could
happen there was a lot of thought at the
Federal Reserve and the academic
profession there it's actually a little
nest of people at Princeton in the early
years of this decade worrying about it
was me there was large Svendsen news now
at the Rick's bonk and there was a guy
named Bernanke Ben Bernake don't know
what happened to him we're worried about
something very much like this but what
we all had in mind was a much smaller
version of it and we thought that the
Fair Reserve by being vigorous and a
reasonable fiscal stimulus would head
off this kind of crisis at the pass and
what's actually happened is this crisis
had been so large the political process
has been sufficiently sluggish the
difficulties have been greater than
expected
that we are actually deep in this and
yes there are some green shoots things
are getting worse more slowly but we
have not managed to head off a crisis
that could turn out to be self
reinforcing and leave us in this trap
for many many years thank you Paul
professor ribboning you're up
well it's pretty clear right now that is
the worst financial crisis and economic
crisis on a session since the Great
Depression you know a number of us were
worrying about it awhile ago at this
point is becoming conventional wisdom
for example last year there was this
myth of decoupling that even if the US
would contract the rest of the world
would happily decouple from this u.s.
economic contraction and usually people
say when the US sneezes the rest of the
world catches the cold this time around
the US was not just needing as a severe
case of drowning pneumonia and first a
financial contagion now the real
continue has led to a economic
contraction from the u.s. to the
eurozone the UK Australia New Zealand
Canada Japan two thirds of global GDP
advanced economies contracting and now a
hard landing also in emerging markets
with severe recession in many of them
slowdown or growth in places like China
and risk of outright financial crisis
currency banking sovereign in a number
of emerging market economies so where
are we now and what needs to be done you
know people are talking about these
green shoots of spring about second
derivatives of economic activity
becoming positive meaning the rate of
contraction is not accelerating but just
decelerating and therefore we're going
to reach a bottom sooner rather than
later glimmers of hope but if you look
at the data in some sense and you look
at the debate about the shape of this
recession we are in a severe recession
right now in the US a year ago the
consensus was Arjun this recession will
be short and shallow v-shaped lasting
maybe eight pounds like they last to
1991 and 2001 and people like myself and
other were suggesting that given
imbalances in the financial system the
over boring and over leveraged by
households and even corporates this will
be more like a u-shape recession 24
months or so and I would argue that I
was Gargan they will even risk of a
something more severe l-shaped recession
or the depression like the one that
Japan experienced after the collapse of
its a real estate and equity bubble in
the 1990s I would say that right now
it's obvious that the V is out of the
window we're already in the 17 months of
a severe recession is already twice as
long as the previous two if this
recession is over even by the end of
this year we'll be 24 months meaning
three times as long and more like six
times as deep as any previous one in
terms of output collapse and if you look
at employment in industrial production
and other things even worse than that
looks like a almost like a near
depression so the V is out of the window
I would say that the good news is
probably that they're very aggressive
actions by the policymaker in US and
around the world I think that six months
ago there was a risk of a near
depression and the policymaker finally
got religion looked into the abyss the
Congress contracting 6% Plus us around
the world and now the decided use all
most of the weapons in their Arsenal's
guns bazookas missiles artillery you
name it monetary fiscal credit 20
different programs because of that I
think that the risk of a near depression
has been somewhat reduced I don't think
that there is zero probability but we
probably are not gonna end up in a
veneer with depression we learned some
of the lessons as Paul said from the
Great Depression even from Japan however
now the consensus is becoming optimistic
again and says that we're gonna go from
minus 6% growth to positive growth in
the second half of the year meaning the
recession is gonna be over in in June by
q4 they estimate that growth is gonna be
positive two percent the next year more
than two percent so back to potential
now compared to these new consensus that
got it wrong in the past my views are
much more bearish I would agree that the
rate of economic contraction is flowing
down if you had the keep on having the
freefall of the last two quarters will
end up another Great Depression and the
policy action reducing that but we're
still contracting at a pretty fast rate
I see the economy contracting all the
way to the end of the year so reaching
from minus 6 minus 2 not 2 plus 2 and
next year the growth rate of the economy
will be so low 0.5% is opposed to 2%
loss of the consensus and unemployment
rates already busy is going to be above
10 percent more likely close to 11
percent next year the diva next year is
going to feel like
recession even if we were technically
out of the recession and the outlook for
European Japan would this year next year
is even worse so most advanced economies
are gonna do even worse than the United
States for a number of reasons
structural factors in Japan weak policy
response in the case of the eurozone now
the financial problem the financial
system if you are still sitting here
many banks are still insolvent I agree
if you don't want to end up like Japan
with zombie banks just believe broadly
suggest is better to do what Sweden did
take over the bank's clean them up
separate good and bad assets and sell
them back in short order to the private
sector now on the question of the policy
responses will be of a debate between
Neil and and Paul and I think that one
of our closer to the views of a poll I
think there is some grain of truth about
what [ __ ] says in the following sense
there is no inconsistency between
monetary easing and fiscal easing both
of them should be stimulating demand and
the monetary easing should be leading
also to restoration of credit of course
in a situation which the prongs of the
economic problems of not just a
liquidity but also of solvency
traditional monetary policy doesn't work
you also have to do unconventional stuff
and you have to fix the banks and we
need the fiscal stimulus because every
component of a grid the man is
collapsing consumption residential
investment capex spending
non-residential construction inventories
exports the only thing can go up and
sustain the economy for the time being
is fiscal policy however there are
caveats the cavity's monetary policy
cannot resolve problems of credit
first of all secondly fiscal policy is
not without costs we need in a short run
we're gonna add about nine trillion
dollars to US public debt if you think
about the problem of the economy neither
said is the end of an age of leverage is
not really there is no deleveraging with
all the liabilities of the households of
the banks of the corporates and now we
decided to socialize these losses and to
put them on the back of the balance
sheet of the government that's why the
public debt is rising when you had that
problem you have to convert it into
equity that's what you do with corporate
restructure to convert some my unsecured
debt into equity that's what you should
do with the banks take the unsecured
creditors
and convert their claims into equity the
same thing you could do with the house
of the reduce their mortgages and have
an upside for the credit in terms of a
warrant what we're doing is not that
that into equity conversion but we're
doing is piling more debt on top of more
debt and at some point the back of the
sovereign is going to break and when
that's going to happen it's going to be
a disaster so we need fiscal Steven
short run but you have to worry about
the long run too thank you no real
there'll be time together there will be
plenty of time to serve some of this out
mr. Soros I think it's fairly obvious by
now that we are in a difficult situation
there are two features that I think they
deserve to be pointed out one is that
the financial system as we know it
actually collapsed after the bankruptcy
of Lehman Brothers on September 15 the
the financial system really ceased to
function and had to be put an artificial
life support and at the same time the
financial shock had a tremendous effect
on the real economy and the real economy
went into a freefall and that was global
and international trade was the one that
was actually collapsed even more than
economic activity it was the worst it
the other feature is that the system
collapsed of its own weight and that
contradicted the prevailing view the
governing view about financial markets
namely that they tend towards
equilibrium and that equilibrium is
disturbed by extraneous forces outside
shocks
and and you have then divergencies from
the doctor Librium but they occur in a
random fashion
but basically markets are
self-correcting and that paradigm has
been proven to be false and so we are
dealing not only with the collapse of a
financial system but also with the
collapse of a world view and a collapse
like this generally events always
outpace people's ability to understand
what's happening so the response is
always lagging behind the problem and
policies that could have worked at one
point no longer work at the next so
that's the situation that President
Obama inherited now in these
circumstances he is faced with a double
objective two objectives one you have to
arrest the collapse arrest and if
possible reverse the collapse a second
you have to reconstruct the system
because it cannot be reconstructed the
way it was it can't be restored so this
is a different situation and when people
compare this with other previous
financial crises they're making a
mistake now the interesting thing is
that what you need to do in the short
term is almost exactly the opposite of
what needs to be done in the long term
because the obviously the problem was
excessive leverage but when you have a
collapse of credit
you then have to
and there's only one source of credit
that is still credible and that's the
state the Federal Reserve and the
Treasury then if you have to actually
inject a lot more leverage and cap and
money effectively you have to print
money as fast as you can expand the the
the balance sheet of the Federal Reserve
increase the national debt and that is
in fact what what has been done which is
the right thing to do but then you have
to do once the this policy is successful
you will then have to drain the money
supply as fast as the accredited
experience so in the circumstances I
would say that policy generally lagged
behind events we were behind the curve
now that the the the the free fall is
moderating and the space of the collapse
has more or less occurred I think we are
we have a good hope that policy will in
fact catch up with events and I actually
hope it will be very interesting what's
going to happen in the next 10 days if
we the stress test because that's
basically where the policy has been
lagging behind in recapitalizing the
banks and that's where most of the
confusion and distress comes from but if
the stress is is really used to to give
a realistic picture of the banks I think
that the good banks will be able to
raise money and that will never
the problem and then the government can
deal with the recapitalization and then
we avoid the the danger that we I think
we are all aware of of zombie banks that
deep in the hole that are going to have
to earn their way out of that hole and
will continue to weigh on the economy
for a very long time George thank you
professor Wells we have done this in
alphabetical order in case you hadn't
noticed this and I'm sure Robin has
dealt with being a W for a long time yes
and I have the advantage of then
following up and being able to to follow
up on what others have said so it's fine
by me I don't have any particular
expertise about what the economy is
going to do today over six months from
now I don't have any particular
expertise on how viable the green shoots
are although I will say that I am
somewhat skeptical because as I've said
to other people the rate at which things
were declining during the first quarter
means that if that decline kept on
pretty soon we'd hit the Stone Age so it
had to moderate at some point however
moderating is not the same thing as a
recovery and as Paul and others have
said I'm not really sure where a
recovery is going to come from but given
that I also want to focus on a somewhat
different point I do think that for
Policy reasons it's important to figure
out whether there are green shoots and
how viable they are but I think that an
emphasis exclusively on that leads us to
the possibility of not solving some deep
structural problems what I'm really
concerned about is what do we do to
prevent ourselves from being in the
situation ten years from now say if we
do have green shoots say if we do start
to have
every say by this time in 2010 or maybe
a little bit later although I do think
that someone you're unrealistic what
prevents us from if the banks have
limped along and the stock market is
back up ten years from now having gone
back in the situation of excessive
leverage and having an implosion of the
financial sector and these huge global
repercussions and in order to answer
that question or at least examine it I
have to take you through a little
economics tonight and a little bit of
history I want to go back to what Paul
said about the global savings glut the
global savings glut is what drove
interest rates down to historically low
levels and if you know much about
macroeconomics you know that housing is
very sensitive to the interest rate and
therefore a housing bubble was
practically foreordained with an
extended period of low interest rates
all right but you'll also notice that
the bubble in housing hasn't been just
in the United States it's been in places
like Spain it's been in Eastern Europe
it's been in the UK it's been in Ireland
it's been in Iceland so Paul is really
correct when we talk about a global
savings glut a global savings glut that
yes impacted us very badly but it's
impacted other countries as well so I
think in order to prevent us from
experiencing this catastrophe and
another say ten years we need to look at
the origins of the global savings glut
and now yes there are some differences
in how those were actually manifest
between the different countries and
those manifestations are important but
let's look for a moment at the global
savings glut on a global level all right
so if we back up and I think this story
starts really about in the 80s because
in the 80s during the Reagan years we
began to
you experience chronic fiscal deficits
and we began to abdicate our
responsibility to raise tax revenue that
could sustainably finance government now
in order to do that we had to borrow and
who did we borrow from we borrowed from
countries that were running persistent
trade surpluses and going to niles point
that's China
that is also Germany and that's also
Japan and as we continue to run these
deficits these countries by keying on
growing through exports they're grew to
be this symbiotic relationship as now
Allah says this Comerica but it was on
several different fronts between the net
exporters such as China Japan and
Germany and the net importers of capital
the largest of course being the United
States all right
this import of capital allowed us to
consistently live beyond our means first
through the fiscal deficits not raising
enough tax revenue to finance the
government and then also through
ultimately the leverage that we used in
housing and in commercial real estate
and in leveraged buyouts and this
continued and it grew because there was
nothing anywhere along the line which
anyone would say halt I think that we
had a situation in which we are governed
by in its administration or Republican
administrations in which it was in their
interest not to call a halt to these
persistent imbalances the persistent
imbalance has led us to pretend that we
could keep borrowing and not having
sufficient tax revenue to pay for the
government and also if your house prices
are rising if your stock market is going
up which is of course it's going to
happen if you have cheap money it puffs
up the value of the assets then that
disguises Oh
of other structural problems such as
rising inequality
alright such as corruption so at this we
also get an increase in the financial
take of economy as we have this inflow
of capital from abroad the financial
sector in the United States grows larger
and larger relative to the rest of
economy so we have what I call a
financialization where the GDP is tilted
disproportionately towards the financial
sector alright how do we start to get
out of this well it's difficult alright
we have a situation which I find that
we're often we're in many ways almost
adverse to bringing up the situation
that we find the codependent situation
that we find ourselves in with the net
exporting countries I thought it was
quite interesting a few weeks ago when
the Chinese many Chinese officials were
saying that it was proper and it was
good economically the u.s. continued to
run persistent trade imbalances with
China that the euro memy did not need to
be appreciated that we should continue
doing the things as we always have and
that the US should make sure that the
value of Chinese assets were not
diminished by fall on the dollar okay I
thought that was very interesting
because it really was a situation in
which it was clear that this was not a
sustainable relationship but no one was
willing to say that and no one was
willing to say that clearly in terms of
the Chinese so I think in order to get
out of the situation that we're in we're
going to have to address these global
imbalances and I know it's easy for me
to say that as I sitting here I'm sure
in my Chinese made silk silk blouse but
we're going to have to start to address
chronic trade imbalances you might very
well see a
shift towards more protectionism we're
going to have to actually do something
about raising taxes so that we can
sustain government rather than depending
upon borrowing abroad I think that we're
going to have to start stepping into our
role one that we abdicated as as true
managers and guardians in the global
economy and that we're going to have to
start to grow up globally and
economically Bravo thank you very much
we're now going to have a conversation
among ourselves I encourage you all to
talk up and even intervene but also to
talk quickly I I did want to go to kneel
however since it seems to me the
consensus was against neo and I want to
give him an opportunity to defend
himself I think most people think the
government did what it had to in terms
of adopting a serious stimulus despite
the debt Neil what do you respond to the
comments and then we'll have a little
discussion on that and then I'd very
much like to move to the longer term
that Robin was introducing and how we
really organize the American economy in
the future but let's take it from here
well if you listened carefully to what
Paul Krugman said he actually agreed
with me because what he said was this
everything was just fine as long as the
financial credibility of the United
States wasn't called into question but
my point is that it will be called into
question Paul of course it will even if
the administration's crazily optimistic
forecasts for growth turn out to be
right yes it's going to be a three
percent growth rate next year four
percent the year after that 4.6 percent
year after that if you believe those
numbers you'll believe absolutely
anything but they are there in the
administration's budget document even if
those numbers turn out to be true the
gross federal debt will rise over the
next five to ten years to around a
hundred percent of gross domestic
product but since those numbers are
clearly wrong and the trend growth rate
of the US will be much closer to
one percent than two four it seemed
reasonable to anticipate a much more
rapid explosion of federal debt to
somewhere in the region of 140 or 150
percent of gross domestic product now
Paul tried to reassure you that the
rising savings rays would absorb easily
all of this additional debt but I have
to point out that what he said was
misleading even if the private savings
rate rebounded to its highest point in
the post-war period it would still
account for no more than five percent of
gross domestic product but this year's
deficit as I said earlier is likely to
be north of twelve percent of gross
domestic product so I hate to teach
arithmetic to a Nobel laureate it
doesn't quite add up the Fed has
committed itself to buying three hundred
billion dollars worth of Treasuries this
year but clearly it will have to buy a
great many more than that remember one
point seven or so trillion dollars are
coming onto the market and you just
assume that the credibility of the
United States in the eyes of Americans
as well as foreign investors is gonna
withstand us at some point you know the
United States does start to look like a
Latin American economy not only to
people abroad but maybe people at home
if the Fed's balance sheet explodes to
up to three or four trillion dollars who
knows how big it could get at what point
of people stop believing in the United
States dollar as a reserve currency or
even as a store of volume for their own
savings and these are the points but it
seems to me the economists who are in a
majority in this panel are dodging
there's a fundamental problem here which
could be addressed if there were any
commitment in the part of this
administration to root and branch
long-run fiscal reform an attempt to put
the United States on a sound fiscal
footing but I see no sign of it at all
the idea that we we make a hundred
million dollars worth of savings or
whatever ridiculous number the president
came up with it the other day testifies
to the fundamental unserious Ness that
is the problem in Washington today let's
allow Paul and others for respond
boy oh dear oh dear indeed
let's talk national income accounting
off stage okay
you forgot about retained earnings by
definition savings and the economy as a
whole are equal to investment the very
whacked in the world very hour straight
deficit is falling or rising the very
fact that we have a depressed economy
despite these deficits tells you that
the supply of savings from the private
sector is in fact the desired supply of
savings from the private sector is in
fact greater than the amount of the
federal government is borrowing if if
that were not true we would be seeing in
fact an excess in demand and that's not
happening I do worry very different
things there's there's a question of as
there are more demand is the the amount
of borrowing that everybody collectively
businesses and the government together
greater than the amount that essentially
the the rest of the economy is willing
to lend which is not a problem because
as I just go back the the essence of
this kind of recession is precisely that
the amount that collectively we want to
save is greater than the amount that
collectively we want to invest that is
the problem you can't get around that
there's a very different question which
is the long-run solvency and I do worry
about that I worry the the with the
numbers I would disagree very much with
you about those numbers but the but
there is the fact we are currently at
about the age of about 60 percent of GDP
we have in the past been as high as 100
percent of GDP at the end of World War
two without having a crisis but your
ability to go that high does depend upon
people's belief that you will behave
responsibly and that is somewhat in
question it less so I hope now that
we've had some regime change in this
country than it was in the past but it
is a problem so there are certainly
limits and that's is one of the concerns
but I think we do need to get these
things straight because one of the
things that is a problem is intellectual
confusion unfortunately while there are
many many real obstacles to dealing with
this Christ
it is not easy to deal with one of the
really terrifying things for me has been
the extent to which just sheer
misunderstanding misunderstanding of of
issues that were settled 70 years ago
has been crippling a lot of the policy
debate and we do need to get these
things straight
can I switch to the longer term just for
a moment and I come back to you on the
long term because Maria wants to talk
about this issue quickly and then I
think it will get to that yes I think
the debate is a bit about what needs to
be done the shorter versus the long term
then the lesson of the Great Depression
is pretty clear the Great Depression
start with the stock market crash and it
became Great Depression by 33 because of
four reasons one within believing that
the cyclical monetary policy the money
supply contracted rather being eased
interested were not falling that made
the credit crunch worse - nobody
believed in counter-cyclical fiscal
policy the general theory of Keynes was
originally in 36 therefore were raising
taxes and cutting spending maintains
balanced budget that made the recession
even more severe three-d-- was this
believe in creative destruction let the
bank's collapse thousands of them
collapse the credit crunch became even
worse and for 75% of house of the
mortgage default about 33 under mortgage
we couldn't they couldn't paid so a
stock market crash became a Great
Depression
then you had currency wars and yet trade
wars then yet protection is tenure
capital controls then your default by
countries that do a raise of nasty
authoritarian regimes in German in Italy
in Japan in Spain and then wind up in
World War two right so those are the
consequence of not taking the right
policy actions and the right policy
actions mean in the short run that you
do the right stimulus now I agree aware
that we have to worry about the long run
we're going to finance this budget
deficit by printing money we may have
high inflation hyperinflation that's
what happened in Germany in the 30s in
the Weimar Republic and so on if we are
having large budget deficits an increase
in the public that we don't know there
is very five-30 10-3 whatever eventually
the only few ways of resolving at that
problem either you default on it like
countries like Argentina do we have
never done it or use the inflate
chantix to wipe out the real value of
the debt or you have to raise taxes and
cut government spending and given the
size of the deficits over time that's
gonna be a painful policy political
choice so we need the stimulus in the
short run we need to have the basis for
a medium-term fiscal sustainability and
during the liquidity otherwise won't
have problems over the medium-term
they'll build deep you know I think that
if you look at the President's budget
there is if you look at it carefully a
potential answer to the dilemma you pose
and that is he's proposed six hundred
and thirty four billion dollars for
healthcare that won't get there that's
not going to get there so that means
he's going to have to do something on
Medicare and Medicaid which are very
large entitlements and I could see him
with the promise of covering most
Americans how many ninety five ninety
six percent saying we can't get there
now we have to do some things on
Medicare and Medicaid and when he does
those things on Medicare and Medicaid it
shows that the growth of those programs
which are driving entitlements are much
less steep it's easy to deal with Social
Security and then you've sent a message
to the world economy that you are a
responsible fiscal government and then
you might get money from China Japan
other countries even though the Chinese
now you know please have oh then they
used to finance 50 percent of our
deficit essentially and now it's like an
11 percent and when it goes to 1.8
trillion it's going to be less than 11
percent
foreigners are going to have less than
11 which brings us back to Paul's point
which is we don't really need the
foreigners because we have increased our
savings
meaning that savings can go into
Treasuries and therefore finance the
budget deficit but if savings go into
Treasuries those savings aren't going
into investing in companies that produce
jobs
growth so it creates a dilemma but I
believe that if you took a look at the
budget deficit or the budget you see the
beginning of an answer and an awareness
on the part of ministration that this is
the issue that has to be addressed
George do you think there's a big
inflation awaiting us at their big rise
in inflation yes look we are going to
end up with a big increase in the
national debt but let's face it for 25
years we have been consuming more than
we were producing the that debt was
accumulated over 25 years of living
beyond our means and what has happened
it accumulated mainly in the housing
sector and in the financial sector and
that's now being nationalized it's a
little bit unfortunate that so far we
have only nationalized the liabilities
of the banks and not their assets but of
course that's sort of kind of a trap be
a full person as we say lemon socialism
bad side belongs to the public and so so
and however and so I think it's it's
right that we are extending a government
credit to replace the collapsing credit
and we have we are currently facing at
the deflationary situation when credit
restarts suddenly there will be a
flip-flop where the fear of deflation
will be replaced by the fear of
inflation and the pressure for interest
rates to rise will be very very strong
at that time the Fed would be
ill-advised to keep on buying long term
that because that would push other
people out from by
that and they would have to monetize it
all and you would have runaway inflation
so therefore the rise in interest rates
is going to choke off the recovery and
so we are facing now a period of stop go
or stagflation similar but more severe
than what we faced in in in in the in
the 80s 70s I get my deck is wrong but
but Torian here that's why you have a
historian here George it's to get the
decades right right but but that is a
favorable outcome compared to what would
have would have happened if we didn't do
what we are doing
let's Jeff can I can I ask a question
because it seems to me the analogies are
being drawn here with various different
decades Paul seems to think that the
1930s apply well of course when Keynes's
rising globalization had completely
broken down and as he said his recipe
was really intended for a closed economy
not an open economy Paul talks in
wonderfully national terms I noticed
this in your columns Paul but the
world's one economy now we have to think
of it as one economy for as long as
globalization holds up now there's this
it seems to me a real problem here we're
looking at the wrong place and the wrong
time for remedies why is this not Japan
what is the difference between what we
are doing now and what the Japanese did
after 1989 they did practically exactly
what we're doing zero interest rate
policy and quantitative easing a massive
increase in the public debt huge
deficits in order to try to restart the
economy and of course the propping up of
the banking system rather than the kind
of restructuring of bank bank debts that
has been proposed by the different let's
let Paul answer right so thank you
no actually on the banking side we are
behaving alarmingly like the Japanese in
fact in many ways now the funny thing is
that we came into this I by the way I
think both the 1930s and Japan's Lost
Decade
are entirely relevant that's very much
the framework in which I think and and a
lot of what I'm saying really are global
issues and I hope we have a chance to
get to this because it is a it is a
global savings glut the world as a whole
has more desired savings than the world
as a whole is willing to invest that's
our problem right now that's the
immediate problem and if I were going to
say the the u.s. the amazing thing about
US policy is that we have policymakers
who thought a lot about Japan tremendous
emphasis at the Fed tremendous emphasis
on learning from the Japanese lesson
decision we were not going to do what
the Japanese did that we were not going
to have a fiscal response that was just
enough to prop up the economy but not
enough to really generate a cut recovery
that we're not going to let the bank
slide sort of propping them up but not
actually fixing them and then faced with
the actual crisis what we have is a
fiscal response that's enough to prop up
the economy but not enough to generate a
real recovery and what we're doing is
letting the banks slide propping them up
enough to keep them from collapsing but
not enough to really fix them so the
we've actually turned Japanese in spite
of an enormous determination at least
verbally not to do that that's what
scares me about this that we have we
this case we thought we had learned from
history and and in the event have proved
unable to avoid repeating it and that is
that is a very frightening thing so on
that I think we're in agreement but at
the point about the Japanese is not that
they did too too much on either of these
fronts but they failed to do enough
which was the policy consensus if you
asked what Larry Summers was saying
before was you have to have a Powell
doctrine you have to hit this kind of
problem with overwhelming force
and what we've instead got is a vietnam
style escalation
let me let Muriel's make a quick comment
on this and then let's go on to broader
issues about the future some sense I
actually think we're trying to avoid the
mistakes
Japan Japan waited two years until they
cut interest rates after the bursting of
their bubble we have done it very
aggressively done to zero very fast
Japan went half-heartedly into
quantitive easing we've done it big-time
Japan reversed the zero interest rate
policy too soon that was a mistake
Japan waited two years after the
bursting of the bubble to do any fiscal
stimulus and then instead of doing
infrastructure to build marinas in every
fishing village so there was not
productive investment Japan imposed the
consumption tax too early there was a
contraction of fiscal policy Japan kept
toombi banks in Zombie you know
corporates alive for eight years until
98 we're not doing enough but a giving
to the crisis were doing more than Japan
did in Japan it structure rigid is like
lifetime employment we don't have in
some sense there are things we can learn
from Japan and do more front-loaded more
aggressive more consistent we're doing
some of those mistakes on the banks but
then there is a difference between us in
Japan as well we have 15 minutes
unfortunately Robin wants to make a
comment on this but I also want to ask
you to begin to talk quickly about the
future and trying to correct these
imbalances and you said my favorite
words which makes me very unpopular
raise taxes in the future so let's talk
a little bit about let's get into that
argument give it everybody a reasonable
chance to make a contribution all right
I wanted to start off by responding to
Neil's point about this being global
economy yes it is a global economy but
it's a dysfunctional global economy
because and this sort of Freeman I'd
view of the way that the open economy
free global trade and free global
capital flows would operate you had
flexible exchange rates and a flexible
exchange rates would allow a way to
equilibrate these
these surpluses and these deficits so
that they weren't persistent what we
have now is a system of complicit
cheating because we have a remember that
needs to be it revalued upwards we have
Germany that's running persistent
surpluses we have Japan that's running
persistent surpluses if we have truly
flexible exchange rates that wouldn't be
occurring but how
to the Argentineans when they got blown
up is because they were pegged to the
dollar so we have to realize that we are
in a dysfunctional situation unless we
actually do something to correct that we
are on the road to having that happen
again now as I was saying before about
taxes needing to go up taxes need to go
up because we have to have first of all
a credible commitment that we are going
to pay off these debts that we we are we
are running up and that's really a
political question more so than an
economic question I think it's also it
also though goes into this issue of we
need to be clear and we need to treat
government as a something that is that's
sustainable and I think it's also having
a larger government at this point can
help deal with a problem that Paul was
bringing up which is that with a global
savings glut we have a situation in
which there's more savings than
profitable investment opportunities so
if you're an investor what's your
expected rate of return - and that's one
way of how in affecting a - rate of
return is to invest in the stock market
and have it all go poof
okay so we could be subject to these
booms and bust as long as we're and what
it does it gives us over the average a
negative rate of return one way of
trying to get around that is by actually
having the government do the investing
in things that we don't we aren't good
at investing as individuals like
environmental policy like universal
health care like better education like
better infrastructure let me thank thank
you let me ask George George what should
the future American economy look like
and what is the role in government in
that both public investment taxes and re
regulation of the financial sector or
restructuring the financial setting well
because we have to start with
recognizing that the prevailing view is
false that variks actually our bubble
throne they create bubbles therefore
they have to be regulated the
authorities regulators
to accept responsibility for preventing
asset bubbles from growing too big
they've expressly rejected that saying
that if the markets don't know how can
the regulators know and of course they
can't so they're bound to be wrong but
they get feedback from the market and
then they can adjust because they have
not done enough or reverse because they
haven't done too much so this means that
is not enough to regulate the money
supply you have to regulate the credit
and that means using tools that have
fallen into disuse you have margin
requirements minimum capital
requirements which of course you still
do but you actually have to vary them
took to counteract the prevailing mood
of the market because markers do have
moods and it is the job of the
regulator's actually you know this is
called irrational it was called
irrational exuberance but it should be
recognized that is that exuberance
actually is quite rational that when you
see when I see a bubble beginning
forming I jump on it because that's how
I make money so it's perfectly rational
what's going on right now after it so it
is the job of the regulator's regulate
however we should try not to go
overboard
towards regulation because while markets
are imperfect regulators are even more
imperfect because not only are they
human but they're also bureaucratic and
they're also subject to political
influences so we want to keep regulation
to a minimum but it has to recognize
that markets are inherently unstable
real
and this year regulation of course we go
into cycles you know we had the Great
Depression and then we imposed many
actually useful regulations both of the
financial system and of the real economy
some of it became excessive and then a
period of deregulation started actually
even before Reagan and Thatcher was
Jimmy Carter that started some of the
deregulation of some parts of the
economy and then we went waste stream in
believe that a deregulate the economy is
best because as George said when there
are market failure dries to be
Prudential Regulation supervision of the
financial system and economic activity
we started believing that
self-regulation is best means no
regulation we believed in market
discipline that means no discipline
because there is irrational exuberance
we relied on internal risk management
models but nobody's listening to his
managers when the risk takers are making
all the profits and then we relied on
rating agencies that had totally
conflicts of interest being paid by
those they were supposed to be rating so
the entire model of self-regulation
market discipline now has collapsed we
have to go to a world in which is gonna
be more Prudential provision regulation
of the financial system the other thing
has happened because of this
deregulation we've gone through this
boom and busts that become more frequent
and more virulent you know the only
period of time in which the US has been
going fast was in the eighties with the
real estate bubble when bust S&L crisis
1991 recession then with the tech bubble
went bust and waited 2001 recession then
we created with easy money easy credit
and lack of regulation they credit in
the housing bubble now with a bigger
economic and financial crisis I think
the challenge for the US economy is can
we grow without excessive credit and
leverage can we go in a more sustainable
way and what are going to be the sectors
of the corner that gives us sustainable
long term growth I think that's an open
question pop when you address this
variety of issues
gosh there are so many things that I'd
like to talk about let's talk about
where we ought to be when we come out of
this which God knows when but when we
come so let me start there I think there
are two big structural changes that we
want to see one is we need to define
analyze the economy we went from an
economy in which about 4% of GDP came
from the financial sector to an economy
in which 8 percent of GDP comes from the
financial sector in which at its peak
41% of profits were being earned by by
the financial sector and there is no
reason to believe that anything
productive happened as a result of all
of that we had all of these extremely
highly compensated bankers who were
essentially just finding new ways to
offload risks on to other people and it
and we really need to shrink this back
down we need a written we need we need a
boring banking sector again this all of
this - ances has turned out to be just
destructive and that's partly a matter
of regulation that we but we need to
accept that that we're not going to go
back and by the way also a political
economy vicious circle here because as
the financial sector got increasingly
bloated its political cloud also grew so
in fact deregulation bred bloated
finance which bred more deregulation
which bred this this monster that that
ate the world economy the other thing
and this is a little bit off better
things we're saying one thing not to
miss is the importance of a strong
social safety net by most accounts most
projections say that the European
European Union is actually going to have
a somewhat deeper recession this year in
the United States so in terms of macro
management they're actually doing a poor
job and there are various reasons for
that the European Central Bank is too
conservative Europeans have been too
slow to do fiscal stimulus but the human
suffering is going to be much greater on
this side of the Atlantic because
Europeans don't lose their health care
when they lose their jobs they don't
find themselves with essentially no
support
once they're trivial unemployment check
has fallen off we have got nothing
underneath when Americans lose their
they fall into the abyss that does not
happen in other advanced countries it
does not happen that might sort of want
to say in civilized countries and there
are people who say that we should not be
worrying about things like universal
healthcare in the crisis we need to
solve the crisis but this is exactly the
kind of time when the importance of
having a decent social safety net is
driven home to everybody which makes it
a very good time to actually move ahead
on these other things thank you Paul
New York future the role of government
and Bill you got the first word and
you're going to get the last word well I
tell you what I feel depressed after
what I've heard tonight I don't know
about you ladies and gentlemen we we are
now contemplating a massive expansion of
the state to substitute for the private
sector because that's the only thing
Paul thinks will deliver growth we're
gonna reregulate the markets we're gonna
go back to those good old days oh yeah
you you applauded because you think
that's a great idea where were you in
the 1970 just just from where were you
in the 1970s when all these wonderful
regulations were in place I don't
remember that going too smoothly but
what am I else are we gonna do we're
gonna print money almost limitlessly
we'll print money that's gonna be fine
too and then when we're done with that
we're gonna raise taxes what a fabulous
package we have in store for us you know
back in late 2007 I was asked what my
big concern was and I said my concern is
that we're gonna get the 1970s for fear
of the 1930s and that is exactly where
the majority of people on this panel are
steering this country and it's very easy
to forget in your ire and indignation at
the failure of the market it's very easy
to forget where the true mainspring of
economic growth lie ladies and gentlemen
the lesson of economic history is very
clear economic growth does not come from
state-led infrastructure investment it
comes from technological innovation and
gains and productivity and these things
come from the private sector not from
the state
if you want to try this albeit model
fine by all means if you
but wait a second wait a second if you
if you want let me finish and comment I
think everybody on this panel is now
biting his tongue and let's let bill
well just including myself Jeff Weaver
let's let's let bill you know work your
fine work no no come on Neal let's let
you see where we're doing you a good
turn by not extending this ten minute
bill has the final way nowhere you go
Jeff Jeff we know where you stand on big
governments and remember your role as
that of anchor the the critical point
here is please Neil my role of anchor is
now to pass it on to Bill I think I
think we understand you're very good so
as we look at the future one of the main
things that we have to do I agree with
Paul on social safety net health
education in particular but we also have
to look at the mistakes policymakers
made in the last 10 years I mean you
know it's not news that people are
greedy that's kind of nature human
nature it is that we made conscious
decisions not to put limits on that
natural human impulse what were the
mistakes in 1998 we allowed investment
banks banks insurance companies to
combine we eliminated glass-steagall
why was glass-steagall put into law
because the last time we didn't limit
greed we got into trouble the Great
Depression and the second mistake was in
1999 the explicit decision by an
administration and a Congress not to
regulate derivatives in particular
credit default swaps that in 2002 were
worth 1 trillion dollars and today are
worth 33 trillion dollars and that
decision not to eliminate derivatives
created the following sequence you
mortgages affect a thousand mortgages as
a mortgage-backed security a thousand
mortgage-backed securities as a
collateral debt obligation a thousand
collateral debt obligations is a CDO
squared and ensuring each one of those
tranches is part of that 33 trillion
dollars and we decided not to regulate
it 384 people in the London office of
AIG destroyed and are not destroyed
destroyed I'm not to blame for AIG you
know why did I accept this invitation no
no no I said I said the London office it
could have been Hamburg 33 people hunt
384 people in the London office doing
the derivatives destroyed a company that
had a home 16,000 employees in 120
countries why because there was no
regulation at all third decision 2004
the SEC allowed banks to go from ten to
one leverage to thirty to one leverage
and guess what once they were allowed to
do it they did it and so if we're going
to look at the future we might think of
undoing those three mistakes and we
might want to remember that the Chairman
the Federal Reserve is supposed to
remove the punch from the party when it
gets out of control and that did not
happen in the Greenspan years the
opposite thank you Bill Gary
just the brief point on Neal's point on
socialism the previous administration
was so ideologically free-market les
affair while wets capitalism and did he
believe in any Prudential regulations
were vision that he created such a big
financial economic disaster the day
turned out to be the socialist because
they were the one they implemented all
these policies that were now govern
intervention if we'd be more pragmatic
less ideological and believing
government can provide the safety net
government could provide to the
insurance provision we would not have
this mess and we'll have an economist
vanishes a market economy where the
governor will have its own role that was
the problem
Meriel thank you thank you all very much
thank Neil Ferguson for being a brave
soul up here I would like to thank the
editor and publisher of my favorite
publication the New York Review of Books